[Music]
everyone I'm here with rock Darin and
rock what is the area of research that
you focus on so I grew up doing network
plumbing and quality of service I still
do a little bit of that but primarily in
the context of a cloud where I do look
at issues of real time in an low-latency
in cloud computing and I also look at
network economics and pricing in
particular you know for example how do
you price different types of cloud
services and why would be people would
people be willing to pay differently for
different type of things and what are
the benefits to both users and and
providers of cloud services so what are
the types of research projects that
you're involved in now so all the types
of projects that I'm involved in right
now so I have sort of two major thrusts
one of them is in the area of cloud
computing we have a couple of different
projects looking at making the cloud
more suitable for real time applications
so aspects of latency and how you
optimize use of resources across
different types of users so that you can
give different levels of service so that
those that need tight guarantees can get
them but you can still use all the
resources efficiently and the other one
is sort of more esoteric it's more it's
a pricing related type of questions or
network economics related type of
questions when you have this sort of
heterogeneous environment with all kind
of different resources which is what the
cloud is right when you can sort of
build your own computer if you want how
do you go about pricing these especially
if you would not only have different
needs in terms of resources but in when
you are interested in accessing those
resources namely you know how do you
want them quickly are you willing to
wait a little bit and therefore you know
what's the trade-off that you're willing
to tolerate in terms of how much you're
willing to pay for those and can both
the users in the cloud provider take
advantage of that heterogeneity to build
a much more efficient system that
satisfies more customers who gives out
more value overall so in terms of a
specific research project what problem
are you trying to solve and what are
some of the challenges there so let me
give you one
project in the area of real-time cloud
systems which is a project that's joined
with two of my colleagues at Washu
sheng-yen lu and chris Gill it's a
project that is essentially looking at a
real-time messaging system for server
lessor micro-services they you know you
basically need communication between all
kind of different processes and for many
application those communications have
real-time requirements so how do you
build a scalable messaging middleware if
you want or infrastructure that runs on
the cloud for cloud applications that
offers sort of these different levels of
latency guarantees right and the way we
went about it was actually a pretty
common trade trait of the work that I do
which is that Budhan analytical
components and a system component so we
first try to build a model that lets us
understand how all the different pieces
of the messaging systems are going to be
interacting and then once we have some
insight derived from that analysis then
we go about building a system and
realize that the analysis didn't give us
half of the story which is not uncommon
right but still the analysis helped
actually inform a number of design
decisions and realize sort of a better
trade-off in terms of how you would you
know you would build such a sort of
real-time messaging system that works
across a whole bunch of different
applications this is the second day of
the Microsoft Microsoft research faculty
summit what's your experience been so
far so I had a great time this is that
you know the first time that I'm coming
here I really enjoyed it it's pretty
intense
alright so it starts early and and even
though it doesn't and that late you know
it's pretty much non-stop
unlike sort of conferences where you
attend one or two talk I mean here I
pretty much attended all the sessions
and I've really enjoyed it especially
the last one that I was in on the edge
computing which is our edge we're out
which is setting an area that's
particularly interesting is there an
area of disruption that you think
systems research will hit in the next
five to ten years that's just ripe for
disruption so I think I just gave it up
yeah
the edge sort of I think you know that
this tension between what do you do very
close to the user versus where do you
rely on the enormous resources that are
available in the cloud right and there's
a you know constant sort of push and
pull and trade-off when you close to the
user you can do think wickley and you
can be very responsive but you don't
have access to you know the amount of
resources that are available in the
backend in the cloud itself and so how
do you figure out when to migrate where
how and where and how to split things I
think is a really interesting area which
tons of opportunity and I think the
session that we just had was a really a
very good example of that very good well
Rock thank you so much for your time
[Music]
[Applause]